[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestros periodistas soy
Armenia Fernández por Andrés espinal el
pasado 19 de septiembre se llevó a cabo
el funeral de la Reina Isabel segunda en
donde Se realizaron numerosas ceremonias
y recorridos alrededor de 500 jefes de
estado de gobierno y diplomáticos
estuvieron invitados y miles de personas
pasaron la noche en las calles de
Londres Para ocupar las mejores puestos
en el acto fúnebre donde se despidió a
la mujer que reinó por más de 70 años en
Reino Unido
fue el último adiós a la reina después
de cuatro días en los que miles de
personas pasaron frente al ataúd de
Isabel II en la parte más antigua del
parlamento británico el féretro de la
monarca fue transportado por 142 Marines
hacia la abadía de Westminster mientras
detrás caminaba en el Rey Carlos III y
sus hermanos La princesa Ana y Los
Príncipes Andrés y Eduardo también fue
escoltado por William y Harry nietos de
Isabel II
la ceremonia fúnebre la primera de un
monarca británico en ser transmitida se
consagró como el primer funeral de
estado desde el de Winston Churchill en
Halley Su difunta Majestad declararon
una transmisión de su cumpleaños 21 que
se dedicaría a toda su vida a servir a
la nación y a la mancomunidad de
Naciones rara vez se ha cumplido también
una promesa así cerca de 500 de los 2000
invitados eran líderes internacionales
los ex primeros ministros de Reino Unido
David Cameron Teresa May Boris Johnson y
la actual Premier también estuvieron
presentes la ceremonia de un poco más de
50 minutos tuvo lecturas y cánticos
religiosos y se escuchó el himno Dios
salve al rey recién modificado para el
nuevo monarca Carlos III
[Música]
Poco después los restos de la Reina
Isabel pasaron en una histórica
procesión por las calles del centro de
Londres hacia el arco de Wellington muy
cercano al palacio de buckingham más de
6.000 soldados participaron en el
recorrido una vez en el coche fúnebre el
ataúd tomó rumbo a la capilla de San
George en el castillo de Windsor A las
afueras de Londres lugar donde cerca de
800 personas presentaron por última
ocasión sus respetos a Isabel II allí
finalmente la monarca más longeva de
Reino Unido descansará junto a la tumba
de su padre el rey Jorge vi Isabel la
reina madre y su esposo Felipe El Duque
de edimburgo
la Reina Isabel II murió a los 96 años
estuvo la cabeza del Estado británico
por 70 vio la transición de su reino que
comenzó como un imperio y se transformó
en la common Wells a lo largo del siglo
20 fue una de las personalidades más
queridas del mundo hagamos un repaso por
los instantes más importantes de su vida
para la celebración de sus 90 años
Isabel II vistió como de costumbre un
traje y un sombrero del mismo color una
imagen que se hizo icónica en su destino
no estaba al convertirse en soberana
pero en 1936 cuando su tío Eduardo
octavo renunció al Trono por amor fue su
padre Jorge vi quien se convirtió en rey
la muerte súbita de su padre en 1952 la
puso en el trono tenía solo 25 años de
edad y su coronación fue vista en
televisión por más de 20 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
[Música]
tras su entronización vinieron tiempos
turbulentos la decadencia del imperio
británico poco a poco las antiguas
colonias británicas fueron reclamando su
independencia nace entonces la
mancomunidad de Naciones en el Reino
Unido se vive el swing mondon de los 60s
y la existencia de la monarquía
británica en pleno Siglo XX fue puesta
en entredicho
después de los cuentos de hadas los tres
hijos de la Reina Isabel se divorcian
uno después del otro en medio de varios
escándalos el clan real tambalea en 1997
la tragedia sacudió a la corona la
muerte de la princesa Diana sumergió el
reino en un profundo Duelo mientras la
reina escudo tras su silencio una
reacción que afectó fuertemente a los
británicos Isabel II tardó una semana en
ordenar que las banderas fueran puestas
a media hasta
quiero rendirle personalmente un
homenaje a Diana ella fue un ser humano
de excepcional talento tanto en los
buenos como en los malos tiempos nunca
perdió su capacidad de sonreír y de
inspirar a otros con su calidez y bondad
con el tiempo Isabel volvió a ser
popular miles llenaron las calles para
celebrar sus jubileos en 2002 y 2012 las
bodas de Los Príncipes Guillermo con
Kate middleton y de Enrique con Meghan
markle así como el nacimiento de los
bisnietos trajeron colorido a una
monarquía envejecida pero también la
garantía de perpetuar la tradición a
través de las futuras generaciones contó
con la empatía del público cuando perdió
a su esposo el príncipe Felipe en 2021
en febrero de 2022 su salud causó
preocupación Cuando dio positivo por
Kobe 19 pero los superó e incluso dio un
discurso para dar ánimos y Esperanza a
la población contra la enfermedad en
junio de 2022 llegó una fecha clave el
jubileo de platino la monarca más
longeva de la historia del país
conmemoró sus 70 años de reinado en unas
festividades que duraron cuatro días con
la familia real reunida y miles de
personas siguiendo las celebraciones
Aunque Isabel se ausentó de varios
eventos por motivos de salud
Isabel fue para muchos una fuerza que
dio estabilidad al Reino Unido tanto en
los malos como en los buenos tiempos
entre el 16 y el 18 de septiembre de
1982 las milicias cristianas falangistas
bajo la protección del ejército de
israelí ejecutaron a miles de palestinos
se los campamentos de
40 años después de esta tragedia los
palestinos siguen reclamando justicia
por las víctimas etel bonet y Diego
Ibarra nos cuentan la historia
era 16 de septiembre de 1982 nohad
refugiada Palestina sabra y shatila
tenía 13 años y el destino le regaló una
segunda oportunidad
sobrevivió a una masacre Gracias a que
se ocultó bajo los cuerpos de sus
familiares ejecutados por milicianos
falangistas cristianos
del mundo donde estaban entonces las
fuerzas internacionales de Estados
Unidos Francia Italia y Reino Unido los
ejércitos árabes El Nacional libanés que
nadie pudo protegernos
la masacre le dejó un trauma duradero
pero al mismo tiempo le da fuerzas para
seguir con la esperanza de que algún día
los responsables de estos crímenes
rindan cuentas Un año más en estas
fechas nohad y su hermano Mohamed junta
cientos de palestinos marchan por las
callejuelas que fueron testigos de las
ejecuciones masivas para seguir
reclamando justicia después de la
masacre Mohamed y otro sobrevivientes
abrieron un caso contra el ex Primer
Ministro israelí Ariel Sharon en un
tribunal de Bélgica pero años después
las autoridades belgas prohibieron el
acto de mandar a presidentes y generales
fue muy triste para nosotros nos rompió
el corazón por lo que pedimos a la Corte
Internacional de Justicia que persuada
al sistema judicial belga para que
continúe con el caso y Luche con
nosotros por nuestros derechos Como
refugiados a pesar de que ya han pasado
tres generaciones en los campamentos los
refugiados que sabréis Atila no se
sienten Bienvenidos en el Líbano desde
hace 75 años nos han prometido que
regresaremos a nuestra patria somos
palestinos y ya sea que tengamos que
vivir oprimidos y con miedo a que nos
masacren nunca olvidaremos nuestra
patria queremos volver en paz la masacre
de más de 3000 palestinos es uno de los
episodios más oscuros de la guerra civil
libanesa y pone de manifiesto la difícil
convivencia a los refugiados palestinos
pesagraciones unidas lo califica de
genocidio este AC sigue siendo un pune
40 años después el conflicto entre los
productores de coca de la zona de los
yungas de Bolivia divididos entre afines
y contrarios al gobierno lleva varios
meses sin solución en los
enfrentamientos se usa constantemente
Dinamita Pese que está prohibido por la
ley decenas de personas han resultado
heridas pero los cocaleros continúan
usando el explosivo en las protestas
esto es un informe de Mary vaca y Javier
aliaga
las explosiones de dinamita en la
disputa entre cocaleros rivales por el
control del mercado de la coca de la paz
están causando miedo y caos pero su uso
se ha vuelto rutinario en el conflicto
poniendo en riesgo la vida de los
propios manifestantes
[Música]
tras una explosión ocurrida en una
protesta el pasado mes de agosto el
cocalero Plácido Cota resultó gravemente
herido Y aunque logró quedar con vida
perdió su brazo izquierdo
agradecer aquí al hospital
por hacerme vivir una segunda vez
la policía ha detenido a manifestantes
del bando cocalero antigubernamental por
tener explosivos sin embargo los dos
sectores enfrentados los han usado para
atacarse causando varios lesionados los
contrarios al gobierno aseguran que se
defienden de la represión
lo usan para defenderse porque no tienen
otro argumento cuando ya son rebasados
no son escuchados la policía también
reprime la protesta con explosivos nació
en las rebeliones mineras contra las
dictaduras militares un legislador
minero pidió al parlamento que la
dinamita sea declarada patrimonio
cultural del país pero la propuesta fue
vetada el senador que frenó la idea
advierte sobre una ambigüedad en el
gobierno
cuando el movimiento social o el grupo
es afín al gobierno
metadinamita cuando el grupo es
contrario como el caso de adeccoca la
dinamita se vuelve un conflicto social o
de posible daño a la sociedad no
el barrio de la paz que se ha convertido
en el campo de batalla de los dos bandos
pide Paz Mientras tanto los vecinos han
construido barricadas en sus calles para
protegerse
Gracias por acompañarnos en
corresponsales siga con más información
en Francia 24 y Francia
[Aplausos]